let's open boxes let's let's just do it
are you ready for this I'm pretty
excited even though this is my account
hi go get you hell
[Music]
song all right we got some some stickers
cool movie know
this is a going well Nick not not a very
good start well uh why I don't want
tracer that's right no 3000 I want you
know what I want come on I want
Nutcracker we're only in by three and i
want road hog have faith nope okay Oh
emote you just got a ton of cash though
it's only 250 were you not even as a
third of a purple skin right now you've
plenty to get up when you get them
yellow all right we're getting dupes can
hot dudes mmm lot of sprays it's all
right I have faith and here's a
legendary
oh I know why that hurts it's only 500
gold deep Oh back-to-back golds no not a
WoW all right that shouldn't be allowed
oh there we go guys Rudy good one that's
good one you got Scrooged all right
we're okay with that 42 to go so how
many we done we've done 11 and you've
gotten for gold the queue Christmas to
you know 30 yes let's go get hype for
Santa all right we really need
Nutcracker though and road hog road hog
and Nutcracker and I'm good oh that's
the one from I wish you could sell like
minute man oh you got a really cool
getty attack all right there it is there
it is there's that Duke guys there's
that dude mistakes were made there it is
tasty delicious mistakes that's all
right this has been I've never seen this
many gold only had there's a Mason too
whoo that's kind of cool who's the may
skin 3,000 yeah was ridiculous
[Music]
I'm seeing a lot of new years my college
says go until next year yeah you get one
box for free just please give me road
hog you got plenty for both of them I
know you don't spend your time oh I will
I shouldn't have bought that recent one
well we could be 500 richer right now
750 Richard oh okay yeah there's uh yeah
alright we're running out boxes just
kidding aside you funny
ah double screwed do we do we duped
screw ders still 5,000 oh my god i had
4601 started while you spent it on
something [ __ ] huh that's true I did I
did spend it on something
[Music]
well that's cool open that present I
feel good about this Oh weapon you got
that yeah yeah I can it be Yeti man yeah
I would've taken a Yeti man and i called
it hello in sick Wow oops across the
board yeah I riverboat that seems about
right
I think that this should not be more
haha yeah okay we're okay with it I wish
it was road hog can't be mad can I know
I technically camp you had
I think it should be a thing that if you
get gold maybe you drop the number of
times you get golden it over the
probability you shouldn't be able to get
legendary skins from the regular class
you can buy regular vonces yeah come on
now wrote on bro hug nope raking in the
gold though you're about to have 6,000
yeah but it's so expensive luck x 28
yeah with 20 wrote on another yeah it's
too that's too this guy complains too
much yeah well you know it happens I'll
try not to but you know what are you
going to do when you open boxes it's
like when you like scratching a
scratcher yeah I think the I think the
complaint is more like seeing
legendaries and they're not like anyone
yeah it's hey up like right now oh ok ok
see maze bay that's what happens so who
are we missing at this point you were
missing zenyatta farah oh we knock road
hog ok road hog
oh you were missing that sorry oh yeah
which is the one that's like the least
which is my least favorite one from all
of them I cat road hog or zenyatta out
of the last box about Roger that no no
it's not highlighted true that's good it
did May's voice line but we do it early
ladies and gentlemen we are winding down
13 15 hot boxes here we go gold gold and
you yeah you've gotten everything but
the one you wanted that's all right i
can i can buy the 10 that's her oh that
one's cool JK so many youtube's asking
if soldier 76 got to thank you kidding
you got a voice line and a thing you
gotta email with the hug polls in the
wrong place I like that one yeah I do
too all right last 10
[Music]
jump your guardian angel
[Music]
new potential nope that's a skin yeah i
think the mid-tier more gold well you
got plenty of by every thought yeah
lucio hockey let's go the hockey stand
up my favorite oh yeah the question is
do you think I'll get one in the next
five skin yes but it would be the way
you want okay haha yep you're right good
not over it's not over still this is
still one of the biggest things that
bothers me is that a dupe legendaries
only worth 200 it's less than a gold box
just like insane yeah road hog
that's her yes which is cool this goes
until the third of January
tube city doop doop city okay we got dig
deep we got two boxes I just want a Yeti
or Nutcracker I'm not I'm not too
worried for you because I know you have
plenty wow I can't afford I can't afford
all three though I can't afford road hog
with Yeti and Nutcracker but I probably
just won't buy Yeti because I'm gonna
get it right now ya go just kidding I
think we did really well for the
circumstances but didn't we got a lot we
got all of these we got every one of
these yeah but we got everyone right
here you got like six other it's ok you
don't know why the one I you know I just
like
[Music]